Hi, I'm George Takei.
A bill recently approved by Tennessee Senate Committee...
...would prohibit teachers in that state from discussing homosexuality in the classroom.
The so-called "Don't Say Gay" law is premised on the misguided belief that...
...by not talking about gay people they can simply make us disappear.
I'm here to tell Tennessee and all LGBT youth...
...and teachers who would be affected by this law...
...that I am here for you.
In fact, I'm lending my name to the cause.
Anytime you need to say the word "gay", you can simply say "Takei."
For example, you could safely proclaim you are supportive of Takei marriage.
If you are in a more festive mood, you can march in a Takei pride parade.
Even homophobic slurs don't seem as hurtful if someone says,...
..."That is so Takei!"
And around the holidays you can sing,...
..."Don we now our Takei apparel."
Speaking of apparel, I've created a t-shirt,...
..."It's okay to be Takei."
I hope you wear it proudly.
We also have buttons, mouse pads, and mugs...
...all in time for Takei Pride Month.
And all proceeds go to charity. Thank you.
And as they say on the Flintstones,...
..."Have a Takei old time!"